hey youtubers is Charlie so because
Korra is on break this week I thought
it'd be fun to do a bonus video to try
and talk about book four especially with
all the craziness that's been going on
with book 3 just try and put things into
context and talk about a few things that
we can be really happy about as well as
ranked my top 10 Last Airbender
characters to appear on Korra also
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winners effective kill kahler-jex and
novelist vampire girl that's just an
awesome name you guys each win Amazon
gift cards I'll be messaging you on your
channels for details
so be sure to check your inboxes today
even though there's no new episode I'm
going to continue the giveaway this week
all you have to do to participate is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video there's one winner per episode
that's why there were three people from
last week because there were three
episodes which brings up a good point
what's going on with book three right
now Nick just casually dropped that
they're going to be doubling up on core
episodes indefinitely
they didn't say for the rest of the
season but for the next several episodes
you know through Episode seven at least
they're going to be doing two episodes
back-to-back each week so next week on
July 11th they're going to air episodes
four and five and then the week after
that they're going to air episodes 6 & 7
by the time we get to 6 and 7 they're
probably going to announce whether or
not they're going to keep doing 2 per
week and I really hope that they don't
it's totally awesome that we get an hour
of core every week but think about it
this way the faster they burn through
book 3 episodes the longer we have to
wait for book 4 episodes and there's
been no official news about when book 4
is going to come so let's start our book
4 mega thread given all the craziness
with the leaks in the way they've been
promoting or not promoting book 3 I
think they're going to make some key
changes to the way they treat book 4 I
think Nick is going to hold off airing
book 4 until next year and use that
extra time to promote the series the way
they should have been promoting book 3
master cebú actually posted to Twitter
that he was going in for marketing
meetings for Korra so if they're
bringing him back to help figure out a
better way to promote the series it
means they are dedicating resources to
the problem which makes me a lot more
excited I feel like the fandom is always
going to do a better job of creating
awareness for the show but Nick is the
one with the actual resources to put ads
and big places so the general public
knows when and where new episodes are
coming one of the really cool things
that networks have started to do in the
last couple of years is
rely on stars with big social accounts
like Twitter and Facebook to drive
engagements with the fandom the best
example of this is Vin Diesel I think he
has like 80 million fans on his Facebook
page he actually used his own money to
make that last Riddick movie of his and
he said the only reason that enough
people came out to see the movie so that
made enough money to make his money back
was because of that huge Facebook
audience it's a little bit crazy I know
but if you ever wanted to say you know
guarantee in Avatar series after a
legend of korra like a book 5 or
something like that just grow a social
audience get like 50 million followers
and crowd fund something so here is a
really good fantasy question for you
guys this isn't like a real thing but if
I ever got some crazy number of
subscribers on my channel here like 10
20 million some absurd number and I had
the chance to crowdfund something what
would you guys want to see me resurrect
I'm so far away from being able to do
something like that it's a complete
fantasy but it's a really fun one to
have I'd love to think that someday you
know if I work hard enough I could take
something I really love and bring it
back from the dead so the big thing I
want you guys to take away from this is
that given all the craziness with book 3
you should be very optimistic that Nick
is doing everything they can to make
sure book 4 is going to be amazing and
go off really really well just keep a
pure heart and believe magical things
will happen once book 4 it gets closer
so because it's the weekend and weekends
are all about having fun let's rank our
top 10 last airbender characters to
appear on Korra starting with number 10
Admiral Zhao he's currently still stuck
in the fog of lost souls as of the end
of book 2 I think he's still stuck in
there right now but I just love how
jason isaacs brought so much to this
character he's still good at playing
villains and zhao voice is so distinct
that i feel like everyone went a little
nuts whenever he showed up on Korra
jason isaacs even came back to do his
voice again for korra book wondering
episode 13 which i think is amazing i
don't know if they used a dub of his
voice for the scenes in book 2 whenever
they were doing the fog scenes but it's
just awesome to think that he would come
back after being such a famous actor
just to do that small part really my
favorite Sall scene is whenever he was
found in the fog of lost souls i just
thought that was so amazing onto number
9 Sookie other Kyoshi warriors as of
right now she's the only original team
avatar person who has not been mentioned
or seen on Korra
she was always a character I thought
deserved more screentime and she is in
the search comic but otherwise we're
still waiting to find out what her final
fate was and if she ever ended up with
Sokka fun fact she is the only member of
the original team avatar that never got
a life-changing field trip with Zuko
each of the other characters got a Zuko
side story whenever it was just them and
Zuko but she was never a huge fan of his
so I can understand why they didn't pay
him off the cool thing is is that
originally her character was only
supposed to be in that first Kyoshi
warrior episode it was like book 1
episode 4 but people loved her so much
that Mike and Bryan made her an official
member of team avatar I think my
favorite Sookie scene is from the ember
island players episode whenever she
tried to sneak backstage to make the
actor playing her act better and number
8 her better half Sokka it actually took
me a little while to get used to his
character just you know being that he
was so over-the-top he was always a
character that reacted to things like
Aang was in this constant state of
childlike wonder Katara was the voice of
reason and Sokka was always the one
would have liked that
WTF style reactions my favorite Sokka
moment was in book 3 when he in Qatar
had to attend Aang's Fire Nation
parent-teacher conference as mr. Wang
fire and do you think that if Sokka were
still alive today on Korra he would have
been one of the new airbenders I mean he
was from the Water Tribe so it's a bit
of a long shot
but if they let Bumi become an airbender
I feel like there's a small chance that
Sokka could have been went to number
seven Fire Lord Ozai
shout-out to Mark Hamill his Ozai was
dramatically different from all the
other voices he'd done but just think
about the idea of Fire Lord Joker
Ozai did go a little bit bananas at the
end so I guess you could stretch the
reference it was so much fun watching
his arc all the way up to sozin's comet
whatever he declared himself phoenix
king that was definitely an awesome
moment for an evil character and in case
you haven't read a lot of the backstory
Ozai and his father fire lord azulon
wanted to bond the avatars lineage to
theirs so as I married Ursa avatar
Roku's granddaughter that Zuko's mother
so technically you could say that Zuko
is connected to Korra on a spiritual
level even though Korra has been cut off
from her past lives I also know a lot of
you have not read the search comic and
that's the one that tells what happened
to Zuko's mother you should definitely
check that out because it definitively
answers what happened
were so I don't want to spoil the plot
if you do want to comment about it just
use spoiler tags in the comments on to
number six his wonderful daughter
Azula she genuinely had some great non
evil person moments like whenever they
went to ember island and she tried to
pick up that boy hands down best Azula
pick-up line careful you could puncture
the hole of an empire class Fire Nation
ship leaving thousands to drown at sea
it is so hard to figure out why she's
still single I know everyone's curious
if sparky-sparky boom girl on Korra is
related to her just because of the
visual similarity I don't think that's
the case but I definitely think we're
gonna find out what happened to Azula
like where she is right now whether
she's alive or dead on to number five
team avatar mom force Katara she was
like everyone's mom even before she
became an actual mom I always loved it
though when Mike and Bryant let her have
fun like she didn't have to be the
responsible one that was kind of her
role for Team avatar though making sure
ADHD
focused on the task at hand and made
sure that Sokka didn't get himself
killed she actually did double as an
amazing healer I'm actually hoping that
she teaches Cora had to use her
waterbending healing technique that
would be really awesome we haven't seen
her yet on book three but I am expecting
to see her pretty soon my favorite
Katara moment was from the
fortune-teller episode when she sees ank
super Ben that volcano lava flow and
realizes he might be the powerful bender
she's destined to marry it was just that
look on her face it was just so
priceless a number for Iroh I was so
happy whenever he showed up in the
spirit world in korra if there was any
character who deserved to get that kind
of ending it was him he actually kind of
reminds me of what Darth Vader would
have been had he not died like maybe if
Luke had died like IRAs son Darth Vader
would have killed the Emperor and
started helping the rebellion I love
Mark Hamill but I think I would have
rather seen that version of Star Wars I
feel like we're not going to see Iroh
again on court just because Zuko is now
occupying that space in the narrative
that I wrote would normally have
especially since he's connected to the
White Lotus now my favorite iron moment
though is whenever he was stuck in
prison and started to train secretly
whenever the guards weren't watching him
it was just like you knew he was going
to break out of prison at any moment and
tear up on to number three Aang yes
he was the protagonist of the series but
I feel like saying the main character
was the most interesting is a cop out
he definitely was one of my favorites
and one of the most interesting ones
though he's been a huge part of Legend
of Korra even when he's only been in
spirit form only characters that had a
deep connection to the spirit world end
up there so I'm hoping we get to see him
that way but it's implied that Korra is
never going to reconnect with her past
lives so I think if we do see him any
time soon encore again it will be in a
flashback but most of the flashbacks
this season are going to be beifong
flashbacks so it'll be tough not Aang I
feel like my favorite moment was
whenever he learned to energy Bend from
the lion turtle he would have learned it
from guru Pathik but he left early to
help his friends I guess that's another
Star Wars reference like whenever Luke
left Yoda early to save his friends from
Vader I think we can all guess that Mike
and Bryan are huge Star Wars fans
especially considering they cast Mark
Hamill as the Emperor Palpatine of their
series number two Toph beifong so many
tough questions still like where is she
that's like the biggest question right
now where is Toph beifong I'm so pumped
to see her in the Lin flashbacks I think
my favorite talk moment is still
whatever she's schooled aang and san
bending and she just did one stomp and
did a perfect replica of Ba Sing se
interesting question has anyone ever
wondered how often she had to clean her
feet whenever she started living in
Republic City I bet she had pretty gross
feet walking around without shoes all
the time it's just like a funny fandom
tumblr question but it was really
awesome whenever Lin took her shoe off
and did the echolocation top thing in
book 1 and my number one last airbender
character Lord Zuko I say Lord just
because he's not Fire Lord anymore he
passed it on to his daughter who we
still haven't met even though we met his
grandson just like Toph so many
unanswered Zuko questions right now I
think my favorite Zuko moment is still
when he first decided to join team
avatar and said hello Zuko here and
there were these scary music cues you
know done done done but now it's your
turn let me know in the comments who is
your favorite last airbender character
to appear on Korra and which character
would you like to see come on next
I know Toph is really high on everyone's
list we all want tough to come back like
in real life as a bonus I would say that
cabbage man is one of my favorites
somewhere on my list not in my top 10
he's definitely one of the best running
gags on both series way back in book 1 I
actually saw this funny theory the
cabbage Corp would secretly be the
ultimate villain of the new series which
I thought was just whole area
yes we actually just saw him in book 3
episode 1 he was the one that Cora
almost hit with the Siamese car so
remember two new episodes of Legend of
Korra coming this Friday is going to be
episodes four and five because of the
funny way that they're doing those
episodes I might just do a combined
review of episodes four and five and
didn't do it like a QA on Saturday be
sure to subscribe to get everything even
though I'm going to combine reviews I'll
still do a giveaway for each episode so
they'll be like two gift cards that I'll
give away in that one review video right
now click here to get my episode 1 & 2
video and click here for my episode 3
video thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives